Traduttore: Michele Gianella
Revisore: Federico MINELLE
"Freeze" è una parola inglese,
che vuol dire: stai fermo,
stai immobile, non ti muovere.
Per me è importante questa parola,
perché è legata al risveglio.
Infatti io voglio parlare del risveglio
come un qualcosa che è necessario
per distoglierci da questa inerzia,
da questo non muoverci.
Ed è importante muoverci in questo momento
perché ci aspetta un futuro diverso
da quello che immaginiamo, con dei rischi.
Il movimento è fondamentale
affinché questi rischi possano essere
riconsiderati in forma positiva.
Ovviamente io ne parlo
dal mio punto di vista.
Io sono un architetto,
e quindi devo capire
qual è il mio ruolo come architetto
all'interno di questo cambiamento,
e di come posso intervenire;
e soprattutto che importanza ha
l'architetto, l'architettura
all'interno di questo contesto.
Il contesto di cui stiamo parlando
è il contesto del Climate Change.
Un cambiamento che implica
non il fatto che ci troveremo
di fronte a uno scenario nuovo, diverso;
ma che questo scenario
cambierà continuamente,
secondo per secondo,
per i prossimi centinaia,
forse migliaia di anni.
Cosa c'entra l'architettura?
Ogni volta che parlo
di questo tema, la domanda è:
sì, questo è un tema
che riguarda i politici,
che riguarda i decision maker,
che riguarda probabilmente
gli industriali,
le politiche industriali e l'economia.
Ecco: questo grafico che voi vedete,
dice che la realtà non sta proprio così.
Il ruolo degli architetti è fondamentale.
Se parliamo in termini di CO2
vedremmo che probabilmente,
anzi certamente,
le emissioni di CO2 in gran parte
vengono causate dalle costruzioni.
Se consideriamo anche
il sistema dei trasporti,
e sommiamo questi due fattori,
cioè consideriamo
come la forma della città
interviene nel sistema dei trasporti,
ci accorgeremo che la città, di per sé,
è la principale causa di emissioni di CO2.
Ecco che il ruolo dell'architetto
diventa importante, se non determinante.
In realtà noi sappiamo, anche,
quali sono gli ingredienti
che dobbiamo utilizzare
per rispondere a questa necessità.
La ricerca ci aiuta,
quindi sappiamo che si tratta
di città più resilienti,
nel senso capaci di adattarsi
a questo mutamento,
e questo mutamento porta con sé
dei cambiamenti climatici estremi.
Quindi le città devono adattarsi
a questi cambiamenti climatici estremi.
Il secondo aspetto è la compattezza.
Dobbiamo aspettarci città
sempre più densamente popolate e compatte,
perché la disponibilità delle risorse
è sempre più limitata:
dipende dal suolo produttivo.
Maggiore è la dimensione delle città,
maggiore sarà la disponibilità
di suolo produttivo.
Questo mi porta a una conclusione, sapendo
che la popolazione mondiale crescerà.
Se non vogliamo arrivare a quella
che noi, nel centro
di ricerca di Portsmouth,
chiamiamo "equazione impossibile",
dovremo considerare un nuovo elemento,
che è l'elemento fondamentale
per il risveglio, ed è la creatività.
Ecco perché noi parliamo
di radical concept,
parliamo di visionarietà,
di capacità di vedere il mondo
con occhi diversi.
In realtà questo non vuol dire
che parliamo di un futuro
e non dobbiamo più rivolgerci al passato.
Sappiamo che prima
della rivoluzione industriale
in qualche modo alcuni di questi modelli
sono già stati applicati.
Venezia è chiaramente
una città radicale, una città visionaria;
ma potremmo rivolgerci
anche ad altri modelli
come Shibam, nello Yemen.
Una città che in tutto e per tutto
risponde perfettamente
alle nostre necessità climatiche
nell'area in cui sorge il deserto.
Una città ultra-compatta,
che resiste ai venti caldi del deserto.
Ha questa superficie superiore bianca,
con un'alta albedo,
che consente una riduzione drastica
dell'heat island effect,
una cosa di cui si parla, spesso,
come se fosse un problema
non conosciuto dagli antichi.
Naturalmente,
anche questa idea dell'essere visionari
non è una novità di per sé.
Sappiamo che esiste un periodo storico
in cui la visionarietà
è stata determinante,
ed è stata determinante
proprio quel tipo di capacità
di vedere il mondo in modo radicale
che proveniva proprio
dal mondo dell'architettura,
o dal mondo dell'arte.
Mi riferisco al Rinascimento.
Che cosa ha a che fare il Rinascimento
con la crisi climatica di oggi?
Ha a che fare perché la crisi del Trecento
aveva caratteristiche
molto simili alla crisi attuale:
una riduzione delle risorse,
una popolazione che non era più in grado
di accedere a queste risorse,
un cambiamento climatico
di tendenza opposta,
ovvero si trattava
di una mini-glaciazione;
e terza, non ultima,
la problematica legata al fatto
che una malattia, la peste nera,
era in qualche modo la ragione
per cui tutta la società
avrebbe dovuto cambiare
in una forma diversa,
avrebbe dovuto in qualche modo
rivoluzionare economie e società.
Questo è importante perché, ovviamente,
il riferimento ai primi due fattori
è abbastanza immediato;
ma il riferimento alla salute
è altrettanto importante,
anche se non immediato.
Sappiamo che il climate change sarà
una delle cause principali di malattie
nei prossimi 20 anni.
Ecco che figure come Leonardo, visionari,
cioè persone che sono capaci
di vedere il mondo
con occhi diversi, nuovi,
senza la mappa mentale
che ha condizionato noi,
è fondamentale.
Come facciamo oggi
a coltivare questa capacità creativa
che ci porti a un risveglio?
Io ho una mia idea.
La mia idea nasce dal fatto
che sono anche un educatore.
Questo si può fare attraverso,
appunto, l'educazione,
grazie al fatto
che i giovani e gli studenti
non sono condizionati
come noi dinosauri
da una visione del mondo
che in qualche modo è determinata
dagli ultimi 100 anni di storia.
Quindi, per noi il nostro lavoro
è proprio di cercare di instillare in loro
la capacità di essere creativi, inventivi,
anche radicali ed anche estremi.
Vediamo qui una serie di lavori
fatti da studenti e da collaboratori
del mio centro di ricerca, Media Hub,
che sono anche, oltre che studenti,
dei veri e propri ricercatori.
Si tratta di Liam Stumbles in questo caso.
Lui ipotizza una città
che viene rivoluzionata
dall'idea di eliminare completamente
il traffico automobilistico
e di riutilizzare
il materiale delle autostrade
per ricostituire un nuovo tessuto urbano.
Qui vediamo un esempio
della città di Oakland
e delle conseguenze su questa città:
come gli spazi destinati,
originariamente, alle autostrade
diventano dei parchi e delle strutture
utilizzabili da tutta
la popolazione della città.
Vediamo che il sistema
cerca di fare utilizzo
delle tecnologie più avanzate,
come per esempio l'uso dei droni,
e il cosiddetto swarm behavior,
la capacità dei droni
di muoversi a sciame,
E vediamo come la possibilità
di modificare, anche,
la performance della città
diventa essenziale in questo ragionamento.
Un altro esempio è utilizzare la botanica
come strumento di rivoluzione della città,
quindi i sistemi ecologici che nascono
dalla modificazione genetica dei vegetali.
Oppure disegnare una città,
come nel caso di Naim Mukif,
ipotizzando che la città
deve essere disegnata
non solo sui flussi umani,
su quelli che sono i movimenti
degli uomini e le loro necessità,
ma anche su quello delle api;
e proprio oggi è stato dichiarato il fatto
che le api sono gli animali
più importanti sul nostro pianeta.
Oppure possiamo utilizzare
del materiale cellulare di questo tipo.
Possiamo capire come si espande,
e quindi possiamo capire
quali sono le tendenze
di questi organismi di riassettarsi
e allo stesso tempo possiamo anche capire
come si può utilizzare
direttamente questo materiale
come un materiale per le costruzioni.
In questo caso lo utilizziamo
come brise-soleil,
come possibilità di rendere
più opache le finestre,
controllando lo sviluppo.
Fino a un estremo come questo,
disegnato da Joyce Kwan,
che è la trasformazione di città
in chiave totalmente organica.
Qui vediamo un progetto
di Michael Brewster e Bevin Liang,
che riguarda la possibilità
di inserire l'automazione
e la robotica nella città.
Questa tecnologia consente alla città
di essere resiliente,
nel senso che la capacità di adattamento
dipende appunto da questa capacità,
questa dotazione robotica
della città stessa.
Utilizziamo, anche se non si tratta
solo di elaborazioni speculative,
si tratta anche di realizzare
modelli che rispondono -
come in questo caso,
utilizzando un Arduino,
a queste ipotesi di progetto.
Fino all'ultima città di questa serie
che vorrei farvi vedere,
che è una città nell'Antartide
con condizioni estreme.
In questo caso quello
di cui stiamo parlando
è della possibilità di utilizzare
queste condizioni estreme climatiche
del nostro pianeta
come delle risorse,
ovviamente limitando
il nostro carbon footprint.
Tuttavia, queste zone estreme
producono delle risorse
che sono utilizzabili.
Qui vediamo esempi di questa,
di questo sistema di città,
di questo sistema di stazioni,
che sono una forma
di colonizzazione dell'Antartide.
Vediamo che, in qualche modo,
questo sistema è molto simile
a quello delle piattaforme petrolifere,
ma il suo obiettivo
è completamente diverso:
è quello di utilizzare,
per esempio, i moti marini
e per esempio di ricreare un habitat
che sia favorevole alla relazione,
per esempio, tra uomo e animali.
Qui vediamo come, in qualche modo,
si crea una relazione
con la fauna oceanica.
Ora, la domanda, quando io parlo
di questi aspetti, è generalmente:
Quanto costa? Quanto costa cambiare?
La domanda non è casuale,
perché apparentemente
è una domanda retorica.
In molti sostengono
che cambiare costerebbe moltissimo.
In fondo la nostra società
si basa sui combustibili fossili
e mantenere questa condizione
è certamente, secondo molti,
una condizione più favorevole
dal punto di vista economico.
La risposta è no.
"No" vuol dire che cambiare costa meno
che mantenere lo status attuale.
Non abbiamo tempo di elaborare,
ma bastano poche immagini
per capire che così non è.
Qui vediamo una piattaforma petrolifera
di ultima generazione
che va a scavare, che va a succhiare
le ultime gocce di sangue
del nostro pianeta
dalle profondità dell'oceano,
con dei danni irreversibili
alla biodiversità.
La seconda obiezione riguarda
le città che vi ho fatto vedere.
Sono convinto che, se lo chiedeste,
forse più della metà di voi
rimarrebbe dell'idea
che sono visioni distopiche,
e molti di voi hanno già detto
al proprio vicino:
"Ah sì interessante, forse - speriamo -
però non ci vorrei mai vivere".
Questo è interessante,
perché probabilmente è corretto dire:
"non ci vorrei mai vivere".
Però cos'è la distopia,
se non anche una condizione
di non familiarità
con una certa condizione?
Perché la nostra
condizione naturale è questa:
noi non viviamo in case
di campagna con il giardino,
viviamo in queste condizioni.
L'80% della popolazione mondiale
vive già oggi e vivrà in queste condizioni
probabilmente molto di più.
O quella a sinistra
o quella a destra, 50 e 50.
Siamo sicuri che questa condizione
non sia una condizione distopica
o semplicemente la nostra sensazione
che l'ambiente che viviamo
tutti i giorni sia confortevole
non sia solo legato
alla familiarità con questo ambiente?
Questa è una domanda a cui mi piacerebbe
non dare una risposta.
Probabilmente avrete già capito
che quelle città
di cui ho scelto degli esempi
cercano di dire una cosa molto precisa,
cioè di stimolare questa discussione.
Per me sarebbe stato facile
farvi vedere modelli
molto più rassicuranti.
Per concludere vorrei dire
che per il risveglio
è necessario vedere, come avrete capito
dal mio punto di vista, il mondo
da una prospettiva completamente diversa.
Io sono stato fortunato:
per lavoro o per ricerca
ho potuto trasferirmi in Nuova Zelanda
e questo mi ha consentito
di vedere il mondo, in realtà,
proprio dal luogo più lontano
dall'Italia, dal mio paese;
e anche dalla prospettiva più diversa.
Dal sud del Pacifico,
e soprattutto da una fauna,
da un contesto ambientale
estremamente diverso dal nostro.
Anche se si dice che 2.000 anni fa,
anzi prima dell'Impero Romano,
la Nuova Zelanda assomigliasse molto
a quella che era l'Italia.
Quello che mi colpisce particolarmente,
della Nuova Zelanda,
è la biodiversità
e le caratteristiche della fauna.
Considerate che la Nuova Zelanda
è un luogo dove gli uomini, [i Maori]
non sono arrivati fino al 1200-1300,
e nel 1700 siamo arrivati
noi occidentali a colonizzarlo.
Quindi si è creato un habitat naturale
estremamente diverso
da quello che conosciamo.
Il kakapo, secondo me,
è un animale che rappresenta
un po' questa condizione.
Immaginate che il kakapo
è un animale che non vola,
nonostante sia un pappagallo
di grosse dimensioni.
E quando deve riprodursi,
sceglie uno delle decine di vulcani
che si trovano per esempio a Oakland -
centinaia, forse migliaia,
in tutta la Nuova Zelanda -
e va in cima a questa collina.
Una volta che è in cima
a questa collina, comincia ad urlare.
Questo è il suo modo di attrarre
la kakapa, la sua compagna,
che per riprodursi a sua volta
sale questa collina.
Ora, io rifletto sempre
su questa condizione
perché io vengo dalla Toscana
e immagino un cinghiale
che salga su un colle e che urli.
Non so quanto tempo passerà
prima che un cacciatore
vada a prepararsi la cena,
richiamato da questo segnale.
Un altro aspetto molto interessante
è che il kakapo,
a un certo punto della sua vita
ha trovato, ha incontrato l'uomo.
E quello che ha fatto il kakapo,
quando ha incontrato l'uomo
per la prima volta,
è questa cosa qui: ha fatto freeze,
cioè si è fermato, si è bloccato,
sperando che il cacciatore
non lo riconoscesse,
che pensasse che il kakapo
fosse un albero, o un una pietra.
Ecco; immaginatevi il successo
di questa strategia,
e i rischi di estinzione
che anche oggi sta correndo il kakapo.
Ecco, vorrei concludere dicendovi questo,
che in fondo il kakapo siamo noi, oggi.
E spero che questa sia una riflessione
che voi condividerete con me.
(Applausi)